hallo everyone halo 5 has been confirmed
for release on Xbox one I'm your chief
newsreader cam and this is the gain spot
news update developer 343 industries the
same folks who brought you halo 4 have
come from the halo 5 guardians to give
it its full title will be coming to Xbox
one but not until fall of 2015 making a
halo game that runs at 60 frames per
second on dedicated servers with the
scope features and scale weeping
dreaming off for more than a decade is
not trivial said 343 industries general
manager Bonnie Ross it's a task that we
at 343 industries are taking very
seriously to ensure we deliver the halo
game the fans deserve and a game that is
built from the ground up for Xbox one
actual details about halo 5 though are
still pretty scarce a lavish CG trailer
was shown off at last year's e3 and
we've not heard anything official about
the project until now Ross says that
it's a game that will hopefully
demonstrate the talent learnings and the
abilities of the 343 industries team a
game that will incorporate the things we
learn from Halo 4 about technology
aesthetics performance and scale halo 4
if you remember was billed as the first
part of the reclaimer saga and
presumably will lead directly into the
event of halo 5 ross also added that the
halo television series and I alongside
the xbox one itself last year will also
launch in full of 2015 might it be
connected in some way to the events of
halo 5 Ross says it will stand alone
from and simultaneously complement the
game but with no halo 4 and no halo TV
series what can we expect from this year
well rumors of a halo 2 anniversary
edition have been circulating for a
while now and Ross has said that the
halo 4 journey begins in 2014 with a
giant leap rather than one small step
sold for more concrete details on halo 5
and to find out what this halo journey
in 2014 is gonna be all about we're just
gonna have to wait and UNSC to the
microsoft e3 press conference which will
be on jun 9th and broadcast live right
here on gamespot com
you